NoNotre collègue Thomas Gerbet
nonous apprenait ce matin que ds
CHCHSLD avait averti Québec de
l'l'hécatombe à venir dès mars
202020.
OnOn va écouter ce qui dépassait
lala période des questions.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - À chaque matin, sept jours
susur sept, je demandais
auaux responsables du ministère
dede la Santé où on en était das
leles inventaires d'équipements
dede protection individuelle.
EfEffectivement, on est venu
prproche d'en manquer. À un momt
dodonné, il nous en restait pour
trtrois semaines. À un moment
dodonné, pour deux semaines. À n
moment donné, pour une semaine.
MaMais jamais on est arrivé
àà zéro. Par contre, ce qu'on a
apappris plus tard, c'est qu'il
y y avait des établissements qui
n'n'avaient plus de direction e,
dodonc, qui n'ont pas levé la mn
popour avoir des équipements
adadditionnels.
JOJOËL ARSENEAU, porte-parole
dudu PQ en matière de santé
- - À chaque fois qu'il y a
unune nouvelle révélation, bien,
onon apprend que le gouvernement
nonous cache des choses, qu'il
mamanque de transparence.
MAMANON MASSÉ, députée, QS,
SaSainte-Marie - Saint-Jacques
- - Alors, ce matin, moi,
jeje me sens trahie. Je me sens
trtrahie parce que je fiais
susur le premier ministre.
LeLes Québécois et Québécoises
auaussi se sentent trahis. Commt
sese fait-il qu'en décembre,
ilil a pu dire qu'il n'avait
cocommis aucune erreur alors qul
sasavait très bien ce que nous,
onon apprend aujourd'hui?
- - Mes invités, Annick Lavoix,
didirectrice de l'association ds
ététablissements conventionnés.
C'C'est vous qui avez sonné
l'l'alarme. On a la liste de vos
cocourriels.
CeCes courriels avaient été
dédéposés en preuve à l'enquêteu
cocoroner. Merci d'être avec nos
cece soir. Et Maître Patrick
MaMartin Ménard, vous êtes avoct
spspécialisé en droit de la sané
mamais vous êtes présent
ququotidiennement à cette enquêe
dudu coroner. Vous représentez s
vivictimes de cette première
vavague. Bonsoir!
M Madame Lavoix, avant d'aller
prprésenter au public les
didifférents courriels que vous
avavez envoyé dès le 19 mars aux
auautorités, quelle est votre
réréaction à cet échange ce matn
ququand vous entendez le premier
miministre dire : on n'a jamais
lelevé la main.
- - C'est vraiment pour les CHSD
pupublics parce qu'effectivemen,
dadans ces établissements, il ny
avavait pas de gestionnaire
reresponsable sur le terrain. Pr
cocontre dans les établissements
prprivés conventionnés, on a un
prproblème propriétaire
gegestionnaire qui est présent
cicinq jours sur sept, qui est
coconstamment sur le terrain por
réréagir. Durant la première
vavague, le propriétaire était
prprésent sept jours sur 7,10
heheures ou 12 heures par jour.
- - Mais vous avez levé la mainu
nonom de 49 CHSLD privés
coconventionnés.
- - 57 CHSLD.
- - Vous aviez les égouts de ce
ququi se passait sur le terrain.
- - Tout à fait parce que j'étas
enen communication à tous les
jojours avec différents membrese
l'l'association qui me rapportat
cece qui s'est passé et qui me
fafaisait part de leurs
ininquiétudes, de leurs
ininsécurités.
- - Votre réaction, Maître Ména?
QuQu'est-ce que ça d'ajouter au
dodossier devant la coroner?
- - Ça vient se rajouter à touts
leles formations qu'on a appriss
dedepuis le début de l'enquête u
cocoroner sur les nombreux signx
quque le gouvernement avait par
rarapport à l'hécatombe avenir n
CHCHSLD. Madame Lavoix avait déà
fafait parler de ses démarches.
JeJe pense que ça vient encore
dédémontrer que le gouvernementa
bebeaucoup d'informations sur le
niniveau de risque qui était
prprésenté par les CHSLD, sur le
mamanque d'équipements de
prprotection, sur le fait que
l'l'équipement n'était pas
didistribué comme il aurait dû
êêtre distribué dans les CHSLD
prprintaniers se rajouter à tous
leles formations qu'on connaisst
dédéjà.
- - Dans le fond le premier
miministre distingue entre les
CHCHSLD privés. En cours de roue
onon aura désigné des directeurs
d'd'établissements. Les privés
avavaient des directeurs
d'd'établissements.
EsEst-ce que vous faites la même
nunuance quant à la circulatione
l'l'information?
- - Déjà au départ dans le syste
pupublic en tant que telle il y
avavait un problème de circulatn
d'd'informations. Les formations
nene se rendaient pas toujours
jujusqu'où elle aurait dû se
rerendre notamment sur le terra.
C'C'était encore pire dans les
CHCHSLD privés alors qu'il n'y
avavait pas vraiment de canal de
cocommunication en place au nivu
dedes très nombreux directives
enenvoyées jour après jour.
- - En même temps les courrielse
MaMadame Lavoix sont éloquents.n
vava les énumérer. J'y vais date
papar date. Le 19 mars.
CeCe jour-là, Monsieur Legault à
l'l'Assemblée nationale a fait e
dédéclaration. L'écoute.
- - Je veux dire aussi
ququ'on a assez d'équipement
àà court terme. Les masques
etet les respirateurs, c'est
cecertain que tout le monde
dadans le monde va en chercher.
PoPour l'instatant, moi, je veux
rarassurer tout le monde :
àà court terme, il n'y a pas
dede besoin d'équipepement.
- - Vous réécrivez le même jour
popour dire que vous ne comprenz
papas pourquoi le premier minise
didit cela. Vous restez sans
réréponse. Le lendemain le 21 ms
::
onon est 10 jours avant le CHSLD
HeHerron.
EsEst-ce que vous comprenez
popourquoi vous n'avez jamais eu
dede réponse significative aux
sisignaux d'alarme?
- - Malheureusement non. Je ne
m'm'explique toujours pas
popourquoi.
LeLes informations que je
trtransmettais au ministère
prprovenais des experts sur le
teterrain.
EtEt malheureusement, il n'y avt
papas d'écho, pas d'écoute de ce
ccôté-là.
- - Maître Ménard, est-ce que vs
cocomprenez l'absence de réponse
d'd'action?
- - Je pense que les courriels
sosont très clairs.
OnOn voit vraiment un contraste
enentre la situation qui est
rarapportée et la teneur du
memessage que le gouvernement
papassait à ce moment-là à la
popopulation. Dans la première
sesemaine, le message c'était tt
vava bien. On a moins
d'd'hospitalisation que prévu.
DoDonc tout est sous contrôle.
FiFinalement on s'est rendu come
àà la mi-avril qu'il y avait une
vévéritable hécatombe qui durait
dedepuis p plusieurs semaines ds
leles CHSLD. Ce qu'on apprend à
trtravers ses courriels et
d'd'autres sources d'informatios
etet que le gouvernement avait é
ininformé de ça mais qu'il y a s
vrvraiment d'action concrètes qi
onont été prises avant la mi-
avavril.
- - Est-ce que c'est parce que
c'c'est trop gros?
EsEst-ce que c'est parce qu'au
miministère renvoie la balle, on
pepeut blâmer les présidents qui
n'n'avaient pas nécessairement
plplus de moyens?
- - C'est certain qu'effectivemt
onon se renvoie la balle de nivu
unun autre. De façon plus large,
l'l'hécatombe qu'on a vue dans s
CHCHSLD, elle est le résultat
d'd'une série de décisions qui t
étété prises par le gouvernement
popour d'une part transférer
mamassivement des patients des
hhôpitaux vers les CHSLD, et
d'd'autre part limitait le plus
popossible l'accès des patientse
CHCHSLD aux hôpitaux pendant la
prpremière vague. On a baissé de
fafaçon très large les niveaux e
sosoins des patients CHSLD, on
ininterdit l'accès aux aidants
nanaturels. Toutes ces décisions
onont eu des conséquences
exextrêmement lourdes. Je pense
quque ça a aussi grandement
cocontribué à l'hécatombe.
- - Ce n'est pas fait encore pae
quque le premier ministre a dit
ququ'il avait fait ce qu'il a pu
avavec l'information qu'il avai.
- - Ce discours n'a pas vraiment
sasa place dans le contexte
acactuel. Il y a quand même 1000
pepersonnes sont décédées en
CHCHSLD. C'est important qu'on n
vivienne à se mettre les yeux en
faface des trous pour qu'on
apapprenne des leçons.
- - C'est sûr qu'il y a des leçs
àà tirer. Je pense que le
gogouvernement en a déjà tiré ac
l'l'arrivée de Monsieur Dubé au
miministère de la santé.
IlIl a mis des nouvelles règles.
IlIl a demandé à ce qu'il y ait
dedes gestionnaires présents das
totous les CHSLD. C'était déjà e
reresponsabilité de s'assurer qe
totout le monde est en place.
IlIl y a eu la non mobilité du
pepersonnel qui a été demandé pr
MoMonsieur Dubé. Je pense qu'ils
onont déjà fait énormément
d'd'actions. Au cours de l'été
202020, on a eu des formations r
lala prévention et le contrôle s
ininfections. Ça s'est propagé à
trtravers l'ensemble du réseau.
DeDes actions sont prises.
IlIl y a encore probablement
d'd'autres leçons à tirer et il
sesera important de réajuster le
titir.
- - Avez-vous confiance que s'il
dedevait y avoir une autre cris,
leles signaux d'alarme qui serat
enenvoyée du terrain serait miex
enentendue?
- - Je pense que oui. Je penense
leles gens ont bien saisi
l'l'importance des experts sur e
teterrain, l'importance d'avoire
popouls exact et non pas par le
tétéléphone arabe.
- - Et vous, dans quel état
d'd'inquiétude, est-ce que je px
didire de détresse... Dans quel
ététat étiez-vous en ce moment
avavec tous ces courriels devois
totous ces patients mourir et ls
nonon-réponses de Québec?
- - Quand je repense à cette
pépériode, quand je revois tous
leles courriels et lettres qu'oa
enenvoyées, c'est sur quelle
émémotion, la détresse que je
vivivais par procuration, la
dédétresse de mes membres, revit
clclairement.
- - On a tendance à vouloir
momontrer du doigt les CHSLD
prprivés conventionnés parce qul
seserait des CHSLD de seconde
zozone. Et ce convoi, c'est que
leles signaux d'alarme sont
ararrivés de ce milieu.
- - Souvent, à travers le systèe
dede santé, un des mécanismes de
dédéfense du système et de tentr
dede blâmer les CHSLD. Ils ont é
lalargement blâmés pour une grae
papartie de l'hécatombe qu'on a
coconnu. Ce qu'on constate, c'et
ququ'au niveau de l'association,
ilil y a eu des signaux très
clclairs qui ont été envoyés qui
n'n'ont pas été entendus par les
hahautes instances du ministèree
lala santé.
- - Qu'aimeriez-vous entendre
dédésormais à l'Assemblée
nanationale à Québec lorsqu'on
dedemande une enquête publique,
ququ'aimeriez-vous entendre de a
bobouche du premier ministre oue
miministre de la santé face a cs
rérévélations? Il a dit beaucoup
dede fois aujourd'hui, personne
n'n'a levé la main.
- - Je pense que le premier
miministre droit donnait leur
jujuste. Et il doit aussi ordonr
lala tenue d'une enquête publiq.
C'C'est la seule façon d'aller u
fofond des choses. Le mandat dea
cocoronaire plus limitée. Une
enenquête publique va nous
pepermettre de toucher à
l'l'ensemble des enjeux
imimportants.
- - Avez-vous quelque chose à
didire?
- - Peu importe le moyen d'enque
ququ'on va utiliser, l'important
esest de faire la lumière sur ce
ququi s'est passé de manière à
popouvoir éviter de refaire les
mmêmes erreurs. Peu importe ce
quque sera la façon de faire.
- - Merci beaucoup. Les réactios
ququ'on a aujourd'hui, c'est que
leles gens n'en reviennent pas e
lala force et de l'impact de vos
cocourriels. La coronaire en
auaurait tenu compte, de penser
quque vous aviez cette
clclairvoyance. Merci beaucoup